véronique sanson tout sort un nouvel
album
c'est le neuvième ça s'appelle mois le
venin c'est ça est ce que tu as déjà
réfléchi à ce que tu allais dire on les
télévisions au tulle être invité non
mais enfin tu vas me fournir l'occasion
je sais pas par exemple si je te dis tu
as une minute pour me le vendre mais ce
que je te dis qu'il est formidable qui
est bien et que j'ai mis longtemps à le
faire ce que vous pouvez dire que c'est
bien tu mens mais
je crois que la seule preuve que je le
sorte sinon je l'aurais jamais ça c'est
un argument tu le vois stéphane style
sans corps ni leçon de choses tous les
fans bas bien choisir le père de mon
fils et je le vois oui qu'est ce qui
fait en ce moment parce qu'elle a un ou
deux qui ont mal tourné dans les ports
depuis maintenant un bon ils ont tout ça
y est maintenant ils sont tous retournés
ils sont plus en meilleure forme que
jamais je crois qu'ils vont sortir un
jeu c'est qu'ils sortent un disque
prendrait stills nash and young est pas
fait pour être toujours comment s'y
trouvent autrement ce qui est très très
beau dire mais quand tu seras plus âgés
tu continueras à te montrer où tu
écriras pour les autres évidemment je
suis encore adam longtemps je sais pas
non peut-être pas le pas été cruelle
pour les autres ouais je prendrais bien
des choses j'écrirai des livres de
cuisine je fais quelque chose qui
prévient listings par exemple quand il
sera plus pourquoi charles dufraisse à
quelque chose que je ferais bien sûr je
vous condamne à notre disposition des
moyens formidables pour retarder les les
le vieillissement et je consens
peut-être mieux dans sa peau
si on se sent by si on est beau plutôt
que se sont dit oh là là je peux pas
aller on peut pas être beau être
complexe suis pas d'accord et je trouve
que si on peut le faire il faut le faire
tu es cigale ou fourmi ta vie du pognon
de côté pendant les années fastes
je ne sais pas c'est pas moi qui m'en
occupe mais j'espère de tout coeur
tu sais pas si c'est confiance à
quelqu'un avec un jour tu veux lui dire
mélange barrette je me retire je leur
graisse je vais en espagne un pool de
l'afrique
si le mec te dis allah pas un mais il
peut pas me dire comment il nous fait
dire non la montée impossible on est sûr
entendu parler des questions qu'ont les
questions qu'ont souvent oui
les pilotes d'avion l'invasion invisible
fameux avion invisible américain qui
transporte la bombe atomique
puis d'un seul coup tu es en l'air et
puis ne manche à balai ennemis ou tu
peux plus le diriger cet avion et tu vas
tu écrasé états comme le choix de
t'écraser soit sur new york ce sont
moscou tu t'écrases aux questions qu'on
a très con alex contre je ne pouvais je
peux pas dire comme il en a c'est en ça
que c'est con mais c'est très content et
genre tu préfères trompait route à main
je suis obligé de répondre à tes obligé
de répondre sur moscou alors à bon ben
voilà une réponse coudre au hasard je
vois toute façon si tu mourrais tu
préfères être incarné ans marguerite
duras ou en maille une bonne roue
ah bon ah oui tu préfères la beauté que
l'intelligence mais il n'y rien ne
prouve qu'elles étaient cons alors
imaginons que ton mec te trompe je
qu'est ce que tu fais tu lui perce les
yeux à perceuse électrique puis le
couple le sexe à la tronçonneuse et ni
l'un ni l'autre
qu'est ce tu fais je d'oise de mon
mépris
ouais le plus absolu combien de la
chance sinon c'est un échange je serais
plus gêné s'y trouvait au lit avec un
autre maître ou avec deux filles c'était
la vertu je serais plus ce serait très
gêné s'est montrée avec d'aussi
maintenant mais je vous dirais qu'il
trouve à canotes mac
ce serait plus normal et toi c'était
obligé de faire l'amour obligé sous la
menace d'une arme
tu préfères et le faire avec une jolie
fille et quand ma clé car mes collègues
ah bon oui bénéfice atteint non ça passe
rien que pour coucher avec ça ne
m'intéresse pas vraiment toujours dans
la série amour dînatoire tu es obligé
qui préfèrent faire l'amour avec bar
giscaro chirac
ouais ouais en jeu dur question à
barentin mais bon s'ils n'ont pas pris
part jusqu'à il est pas mal est bon et
chirac n'est pas mal mais il faut
choisir je choisirais tu es obligé de
choisir
eh ben
ce quart alors ah ben ouais plaisir
alors imagine que tu adoptes des enfants
tu préféré adopter des jumeaux
cleptomane des jumelles pyromanes
c'est merveilleux ces questions c'est le
vent qui s'imposera pas à temps alors
deux jumelles pyromane ou deux jumeaux
qu'elle tenait exactement
écoute c'est plus rigolo les jumeaux
capte mal parce qu au moins ils
ramèneront des trucs en voilà une bonne
référence
est-ce que tu serais prêt à mourir pas
prêtes à mourir pour que y ait plus
jamais de chômeurs en france
non tu meurs tout de suite ah non non je
suis pas prête
pourquoi moi parce que c'est toi papa
tabouret pour têtu pourquoi tu es prête
à mourir par exemple auquel plus jamais
une inondation bangladesh tes pattes à
mourir je suis pas prête et chef je suis
prête à mourir pour rien dire rien du
tout non plus même si à plus jamais de
pauvres sur la terre pendant les siècles
édition il faut que ça aille très vite
alors ce qui dégoûte le plus c'est la
scatophilie la nécrophilie
alors la scatophilie c'est quoi ces gens
qui mangent des délais chose des votants
et la nécro fils ait des gens qui
mangent des gens morts
bon jeu des cadavres c'est ce qui les
excite si tu le sais tu manges et l'état
leur a alors qu'est ce qui te coûte le
moins banal micro filho moitié de la
viande où on mange d'abord morte alors
ah bon oui nous allons messieurs réponse
est bien donc c'est la nécrophilie tu
préfère manger un cadavre que manger des
extrêmes parce que si je mourais enfin
présent je mangerais bien un cadavre je
mange crois pas que je mangerai
les choses en dernière question con tu
pars sur un vaisseau spatial pour un
voyage qu'il a duré à peu près 4 50 voix
c'est long et que tu peux amener un seul
passage et enfin le client c'est une
passagère est ce que tu as oui tu
préfères france gall ou catherine là à
moi je connais mieux catherine d'arabes
france gall je crois que j'aimerais
mieux catherine laprise contraire ça
restera il se passait le wild
ah bon tu croyais je me dois aussi
attention non mais ce qu'on se marre
bien avec 4 m
je ne dis pas qu'on se marre pas bien
avec françois je la connais moins bien
donc c'est catherine lara pendant quatre
ans en quatre ans avec un peut-être un
mayer véronique sanson bonsoir
tu nous as fait un 33 tours qui
s'appelle mois le venin le premier 45
tours c'était à la fin ça fait une drôle
d'histoire quand il faut bien le dire
une rôtissoire c'est une fille drôle
d'histoire
un petit peu monté par la presse je dois
dire
[Musique]
je leur en veux beaucoup pourquoi ça
s'est passé comment tu as reçu des
menaces
les a reçus comment ces menaces je vais
être reçus à l'olympia par téléphone pas
du tout alors l'année et bon que j'avais
marqué sur cette terre il y avait marqué
des choses entre avait des choses qui
pourraient te faire dresser les cheveux
sur la tête
je peux dire un exemple entre l'exemple
m'affecte à moi le plus peur c'est nous
allons te vitriolé ta tronche de merde
voilà et 1 entre tous
[Musique]
et ça c'était assez tracteurs dont tu as
pas chanter la chanson je n'ai pas
chantées par ce que ça valait pas le
coup bien le jeu n'en valait pas la
chandelle
alors vous avez sorti un autre 45 tours
dans la foulée qui s'appelait paranoïa
et tu as dit que j'avais été très très
abattu par le manque de réactions
justement serre que tu y as eu ta
réaction à toi qui a été de ne pas
chanter la chanson il ya eu à part ça
pas trop de réactions c'est vrai à
quelqu'un comme michel berger par
exemple qui avait produit le morceau
même si c'est toi qui avais écrit les
paroles et la musique qui est quelqu'un
de plutôt engager enfin était toujours
des trucs pour défendre les petits
africains pour défendre les droits de
l'homme
il a pas il a pas dit grand chose là il
fait des choses pour défendre des petits
africains et il fait des choses pour
tuer il fait des choses qui
l'intéressent lui qui ne soit pas
intervenir tant l'espèce de te d'horreur
qui m'est arrivé je lui en veux
absolument pas ou peut-être un petit peu
parce qu'il a une âme
chez moi
mais je lui en veux pas du tout parce
que ça n'a rien à voir lui défend ce
qu'il a envie de défendre et il fait
d'un rituel et quand tu lis dans la
presse aujourd'hui en connaît les
limites de sa révolte
ça fait quoi les gens de la presse ont
été totalement
valet
comment dire
ils ont été faites
comme des hyènes et ça les arrangeait
ils ont été comme des hyènes ils sont
allés vers noir et vert cette situation
là
comme s'il n'avait rien d'autre à main
si tu fais attention maintenant avant
d'écrire une chanson non jamais ouais
t'as fait une chanson qui s'appelle
juste un peu d'air pur qui est sur
l'écologie le pas peur d'avoir des
menaces d'un trust chine lettre de
renault couleurs de bayonne la vapeur
non je pense pas je pense pas qu'ils
agissent comme ça je pense qui peut-être
que j'aurai un accident de voiture mais
je m'en inspire et voilà des rouges
méchoui on s'est gentiment dans les
spiritueux dont les restos du coeur tu
fais la tournée des tournées d'enfoirés
faut bien le dire c'est le nom de la
tournée avec kiel
tu connais tes copains bien sûr il ya un
musée accueille magne sartini il ya
eddy mitchell et toi pognon de la
tournée va être donné les restos du
coeur on espère que ça va pas et puis
aussi la mesure 2 m on a tous pu
retomber d'un album
elle a enregistré
reste une affaire avec l'opéra avec leur
caisse de prague avec l'orchestré
symphonique de prague
je vais faire le châtel et je vais jouer
certaines chansons triés sur le volet
avec cet orchestre
alors tu sais c'est drôle parce que j'ai
déjà joué avec un orchestre symphonique
à montréal avec l'orchestré symphonique
de québec et c'était absolument
fabuleuse mais on n'était pas autant en
fait et pour moi ça me paraissait
absolument insensé on était juste 60 ans
nous et je crois que ça va être
merveilleux où et c'est quand c'est au
châtelet
du 26 au 31 décembre c'est pour les
fêtes en plus de noël ouais cadeau de
fin d'année
j'accueille véronique sanson
[Applaudissements]
salut ça va très heureux de vous voir
véronique oui moi aussi parce que ça
fait très longtemps ça fait une paye aux
devoirs en forme avec un nouveau cd sur
le point de remonter sur scène
alors c'est vrai qu'en 2002 vous vous
apprêtiez à remonter sur scène et puis
vous avez été obligé de obligé d'annuler
à l'époque ça va mieux là non ça va pas
mieux
je suis obligé de vivre avec alors avant
de parler du nouvel album on va se faire
un petit flashback didier
nous devons tuer
[Musique]
et
quand je
[Musique]
coc
si je fait
à
c'est le jeu
100 euros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
là
pas
je sais
[Musique]
à
évidemment
[Musique]
m
dans
[Musique]
il n'a pas le faire
et ma mère malade
je n'ai pas laissé
m
il n'a pas le père
après venir
le pain
[Musique]
oh
à quoi sert la voir
pourquoi veut-on
de quoi mais tu de guerre
tout le monde fermera
le gagnant
et le
[Musique]
il a
il
de galles dans les ruelles
[Musique]
dans al fayed qui appelle
les deux pays n'ont jamais
la tour
m
[Musique]
d'imaginer
dans l'ordre
dumont
a détruit
ou le pays
bien 1105 alors le bien
les derniers mois cependant entendu est
extrait du nouvel album de véronique
sanson qui s'appelle longue distance et
le morceau s'appelle gémenos experts de
son nouvel album longue distance
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est une chanson quand on écoute
un petit peu les paroles c'est une
chanson assez assez menaçante qu'en
maintenant en fait c'est une chanson
vraiment qui concerne tout le monde dira
ccg mana mais vous pourrez dire j'aime
une femme c'est très universel c'est
simplement on dit ne fais pas chier
ouais parce que si tu me fais chier
c'est toi qui vas morfler et j'ai peur
pour toi que tu m'abandonnes ouais c'est
pas que j'ai peur pour moi je m'en fous
parce que c'est un [ __ ] à une autre
chanson qui s'appelle la douceur du
danger par les paroles sont très très ma
vie sentimentale n'est plus qu'un vide
sidéral rien à regarder dans ma boule de
cristal
oui vaka sarine jeudi à bamako
non non c'est vrai et ma vie non c'est
vrai c'est quand on n'a rien à dire
quand on a rien pas même pendant six ans
n'a pas envie d'écrire on n'a pas envie
de 2
on n'a pas de vécu on n'a pas de d'amour
on n'a pas de
on n'a rien donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on
ferme sa gueule ça a duré six ans le
l'incapacité finalement capacités c'est
pas c'est pas que je n'étais pas capable
c'était simplement que je que je m'en
foutais complètement j'avais rien à dire
je ne vivais rien j'ai franchement je
n'avais rien à dire mais rien rien de
rien j'ai planté mes carottes je peux je
plains
comment commencer revenus l'envi décrire
le beau le goût de la vie simplement
l'urgence simplement quand on m'a dit on
m'a dit tu rentres en style studio le 18
et moi j'ai dit mais j'ai rien près j'ai
rien de près et donc j'ai écrit à toute
vitesse
pas mal pour un truc écrit à toute
vitesse dit non mais à toute vitesse
ça veut pas dire bâcler ce n'est pas
bâcler gens ont dit que le peintre
auxerre de la fleur pendant 20 ans et
qu'y la croque en tant que seconde voilà
pendant six ans temps magazine et voilà
il ya une autre chanson qui s'appelle
cinquième étage alors c'est drôle parce
que vos parents avaient acheté un
appartement au cinquième étage oui il
s'était donné beaucoup de mal pour
acheter sa part félicité vais te donner
beaucoup de mal j'avais je sais je me
souviens qu'ils avaient des chaussures
en papier un à l'époque parce qu'ils
avaient il avait plus un rond et puis
que c'était la fin de la guerre qu'ils
étaient tous des cas si fier qui
s'étaient tous au pouvoir et puis je me
suis aperçu que le 5e étage
c'était eux et puis le 5e étage c'est ma
soeur ouais le 5e étage c'est moi aussi
et et tout le monde que j'aime vie au
cinquième étage
poursuivi par cinquième étage
franchement franchement je voulais
écrire quelque chose pour ma famille
parce que quand quand on aime les gens
il faut il faut leur dire qu'on les aime
avant que ce soit trop tard ces rares
moments où vous étiez malade je vous ai
dit si je disparaissais je voudrais leur
laisser quelque chose avant de partir et
qui sont malades et il faut qu'ils
entendre une chanson voilà alors votre
père était était avocat mais il était
avocat et ont ils à tous deux il était
député du 13e avant volant il est il
était
économiste il travaillait avec giscard
et puis avec chirac aussi souhaité ou
non mais il était cité c'était un type
et absolument extraordinaire ans
s'étaient rencontrés pendant la
résistance
oui pendant la résistance et donc qu'ils
ont maman était enfin ils étaient tous
les deux dans le renseignement
papa organisé par exemple grâce à ces
renseignements le les bombardements
contre les allemands sur l'afrique du
nord et en italie et à corfou aussi et
et à corfou bien sûr et à corfou et puis
maman et est une très grande sabots deux
à wii elle était spécialiste en en
sabotages et en vraiment en plastique
elle s'y connaît
moi j'ai voulu un jour j'avais une
souche mais il enleva bhl énorme souche
et je suis dit mais monde
hilton - la recette du plastique jamais
voulu me le dire moi même la recette
docteur sandwich mais jamais de nerfs
elle est très comme ça ta mère regarde
tous ces petits détails
[Applaudissements]
alors je les embrasse et papa je
t'embrasse
il vous regarde là alors votre père donc
et votre mère se sont rencontrés pendant
par la résistance
il sait très mélomane est très jeune ils
vous ont mis à la musique alors vous ce
qui est incroyable c'est que vous
connaissiez pas le solfège et en fait
vous entendiez la chanson jouée par le
par le professeur de piano et vous la
répétiez en faisant semblant de
déchiffrer une partition et un jour ce
n'est pas la bonne partition et la prof
ces salles on s'est aperçu qu'en fait
c'était voilà quoi vous saviez pas non
qu'elle s'est aperçue que je l'avais
berné pendant quand même pas mal
d'années et elle s'appelait mahina robur
et puis aussi pim pim qui doit être
archi morte maintenant bien sûr pas sûr
c'est bon elle est morte
alors à l'âge de 13 ans vous écrivez vos
premières chansons ce qui est assez
précoce et à 14 ans un jour vous êtes à
monaco il ya une bombe qui explose dans
votre tête
véronique sanson c'est à dire que vous
croyez que c'est un attentat au départ
c'est vrai j'ai une bombe dans ma tête
c'était et ça s'appelle tout simplement
une méningite et et puis l'avoir mangé
j'en ai bavé parce que papa est ce que
en plus j'ai reçues quand même l'extrême
onction
ouais non c'était grave c'est à dire
vive était atteinte d'une méningite quoi
vous étiez quand même donné pour mort de
votre père vous a ramené à paris tout
raide à raide comme la justice
ça existe mais la vie et ma soeur
violaine me gaver de déviants fruité à
l'époque me souvenais de de l'evian
fruité avec des clubs semblaient six
bonnes classis et moi évidemment non je
pouvais pas je peux pas puis en bon
après on m'a emmené à l'hôpital et que
et ben voila je suis resté un jour
d'hosto deux mois de combats les 100
jours et tu parles qui ont plus des
ponctions lombaires exactement trois
jours s'était fait les ennemis mais on
s'en rend pas compte mais je m'en
souviens plus que j'ai perdu la mémoire
après tout ce qui s'est passé avant 65
vous l'avez oublié oui même les jours où
j'étais protégé pognon j'étais les rangs
du fait des espèces de réminiscences
comme ça à terre par exemple quand vous
voyez des bagues en toc vous vous dites
ça vous rappelle quelque chose mais vous
savez pas quoi puisque vous avez perdu
la mémoire
pendant sa débat quant à la wells à vous
le fais là
moi j'ai toujours eu quand vous voyez
des wagons tone dub avantage voilà vous
vous dites que ça vous rappelle quelque
chose mais vous savez pas quoi c'était
quelque chose qui a dû arriver avant
1965 avant la méningite j'imagine alors
véronique à l'adolescence vous montez
votre premier groupe avec votre soeur et
françois berne même qui depuis est
devenu un compositeur connu puisqu'il
travaille pour patricia kaas le groupe
s'appelle les roches martin vous fait
vos premiers disques vous rencontrer
michel berger vous découvrez votre
fameux vibrato qui a fait votre votre
gloire vos premières scènes au premier
tube est là quand ça commence à vraiment
bien marché pour vous vous plaquer tout
comment ça je pense tout bas ou plaqué
tout à spine d'agout plaques et où vous
partez aux états unis avec stephen
stills
ah oui vous en souvenez ça quand même
oui ça fait quand même une sacrée
histoire de rappeler à nos avis et fun
style ces grosses bêtes il lâché après
young qui plus de monde d'ailleurs
et puis tellement lourd je vous flashez
sur ses fans s'ils sur les sur les
champs elysées et puis du jour au
lendemain sans prévenir personne sans
prévenir à michel berger sans prévenir
vos parents vous partez d'abord aux
états unis à new york où j'ai je me
souviens très bien d'avoir atterri et
été je suis allé un concert où il y
avait mais alors quelqu'un dont je suis
un grand une grande fan itude c'est
indigne ou même un et on met une chaise
sur scène j'ai une chance pas possible
de vieux cons m comme ça et j'ai trouvé
je me suis dit c'est ça new york
c'est ça les états unis
c'est ce à quoi et après on est parti en
angleterre se marier c'est vrai que j'ai
abandonné quelque chose qui me et j'ai
abandonné quelque chose de doute
terriblement important alors quand vous
partez en fait partie comme ça sur un
coup de tête quoi oui hein
et alors vos parents préviennent à vos
parents préviennent interpol c'est à
combourg cherche
oui ouais moi j'avais été piqué mon
passeport
chez mes parents puis voilà et puis moi
je suis parti je me suis dit ce scénario
un rfg un train à prendre
voilà il faut que je le prenne le train
s'était pas que vous l'aimiez michel
berger quand même non bien sûr je
l'aimais mais pourquoi vous êtes parti
alors pour rire
ouais juste pour rire pour un peu pour
connaître quelque chose d'autre bien sûr
que je l'aimais j'aime toujours j'ai
fait un concert avec un symphonique
justement pour me dédouaner et pour
payer ma dette
quand vous épousez stéphane steels à
l'époque
est-ce que c'est pas un peu pour
justifier votre départ si si si je me
suis absolument marier par politesse
mais c'est ça parce que tout le monde
était là il y avait les beatles y avait
les vous qui avait dont je me foutais
complètement mais il y avait mes parents
et ses parents et je me suis dit je peux
pas je pensais à ma soeur m'a dit moi
j'ai ma voiture là tu sûr on se casse
jeudi quand même si
c'est mal élevé devant les beatles etc
tous ces cas le sandwich et ben je me
suis pas et par politesse mais j'ai bien
fait parce que j'ai beaucoup aimé cet
homme ne mène pas comme michel michel
c'est ce sera toujours quelque chose je
sais pas comment mais le jour du mariage
est consciente qu'il est en train de
faire une connerie
ah oui vous êtes allemand puis c'est une
énorme connerie mais je me dis mais tous
les gens sont là c'est effrayant
et en plus on avait une mairesse en
angleterre donc c'est là l'angleterre
histoire l'angleterre qui ressemblait
comme tous deux à groucho marx
javascript qui me dit un ornithorynque
merci d'envoyer donc là vous avez le
sentiment en fait d'entrer en enfer le
jour du mariage alors la seule bonne
nouvelle c'est votre fils christopher
stills 1
quand même et alors là ça commence par
là vous avez connu vous la vraie vie de
rock star des années 70 quoi c'est à
dire marijuana lsd kokari trop light pro
sonnantes
non lsd et cocaïne héroïne d un tout
petit peu quand même sa cocaïne un peu
un peu plus
enfin pas autant que les autres
heureusement les connaître donc j'ai
connu est alors après six ou sept ans
avec stephen style seul le couple ça
vire au cauchemar parce que lui qui
collent pas mal il se défonce pas mal et
il est assez violent avec vous non ah
oui ça alors du très violent et j'ai
reçu des coups de couteau dans le dos et
ça fait pas du bien
les cicatrices ouais encore mais oui
bien sur les i la pâte avec le manche
ouais et non mais heureusement il me
rater un
heureusement il m'a raté vie m'a donné
aussi un coup de couteau dans la main
juste avant un concert et ben jusqu'en
jouer ou y ait du sang par terre alors
le sens et ce qui est effrayant de sueur
sur scène c'est que le sang d'abord ça
c'est affreux parce que ça ça glisse
puis après ça colle à sa cour est arrivé
non ça va ça c'est les wc c'est la
petite histoire enfin c'est la grande
histoire du rock and roll c'est vrai non
mais vraiment aux gens qui avaient des
choses absolument paroxystique à cette
époque bien sûr lui dit non ce n'est
jamais
alors
le plus difficile pour vous ça a été
d'obtenir la garde de votre fils parce
qu'au départ vous aviez le droit de le
voir une fois toutes les trois semaines
à condition de rester aux états unis
et là vous êtes aperçu de ce qui pouvait
se raconter dans ce genre de procès dans
ce genre d'histoire cirque par exemple
on disait aux états unis que les
français mettaient du cognac dans le
biberon
mais ces envois vous accusez le même but
que d'actualité
oui les français vous vous ayez raison
parce que au moins nous on se tape une
nuit d'enfer mais vous mettez du cognac
ils s'endorment
et puis aussi qu'on faisait dormir nos
bébés dans les tiroirs
oui quand ils sont petits bien sûr tout
le monde d'ordre les tiroirs quand vous
êtes arrivé en france après ce séjour
américain véronique ça a été terrible
pour vous parce que d'un seul coup vous
sortiez quand même de cette vie
absolument délirantes et puis vous vous
retrouvez dans votre maison sur les
bords de seine avec etienne chicot cdu
est quand même grave descente non ah oui
alors ça c'était une grave descente je
veux bien croire ça c'est une grave des
jeunes croient pas à cause de la
descente des états unis j'en dirai pas
plus ouais et qui après gaza
concernant
pourquoi
m
alors j'étais très en avance parce que
allah c'était en 1988 et c'était
l'histoire d'une femme kamikaze
la fille elle va avec sa robe rose avec
une bombe sous sont sous sa robe en
prétendant être enceinte ou quelque
chose comme ça et puis elle va se
suicider au nom d'allah qu'il promet le
paradis éternel et c'est ça que c'est
comme ça qu'on a les gens et âgées je
trouvais que c'était à l'époque
enfin il y avait une espèce
d'intolérance à trausse quoi et puis
d'envoyer des petits ses cd jantes 18
ans jantes 16 ans des gens de 20 ans et
si jamais des vieux un sait jamais non
ils ont volé petit roi c'est ça les
arrange
en plus ces espèces de mensonges de
toutes les religions de toutes les
religions les religions menthe
alors on peut très bien croire à un être
supérieur disons ou un ange irradiant
moi je crois au mien il s'appelle henry
a lui échoué
sinon je serais morte depuis longtemps
c'est pour ça je vous ai tout à l'heure
je suis tellement content de ne
réveiller violente
c'est grâce à lui mais je crois pas à un
dieu qu'à une barbe est sur un petit
nuage ça j'y crois pas je crois pas ce
qu'on nous dit dans la bible je crois
pas ce qu'on nous dit dans l'est dans
l'évangile catéchisme la con je suis
désolé pour les prêtres et les gens qui
sont bien enfin les gens qui sont
vraiment bien parce que j'en ai connu
moi mais autrement tous les autres ils
apprennent le pire
le purgatoire qu'est ce que c'est le
purgatoire c'est quoi non mais
franchement c'est quoi c'est un resto ya
que des sandwichs
la vision que j'en ai à l'époque vous
avez eu des menaces à l'époque de hal à
des menaces des islamistes
je crois pas que ce soit des sages
étaient des islamistes je crois que
c'était à l'époque ddd direct des
skinheads et des gens d'extrême droite
parce que j'ai reçu tellement de lettres
n'ont pas d'islamisme et de musulmans et
qui m'ont dit on a honte on a honte
et puis après il ya ça je te l'avais pas
une grosse
c'est ça qu'il faut une grosse avec des
cheveux courts bien sûr depuis tout
petit sur des grosses qui avait des
cheveux courts et vous irez à pierre ah
oui oh oui vie continue à me faire rire
bien sûr ça ça nous a fait énormément de
peine quand on s'est mariés que tout le
monde dise que c'était que c'était de la
foutaise et tout ça nous a fait de la
peine ça fait de la peine à lui la peine
à moi surtout parce que lui il plus fort
que moi et il s'en sort mieux que moi et
ça nous a fait de la peine et 22 divorce
aussi je regrette rien parce qu'on est
toujours aussi amis et on est toujours
aussi mais pour les freins pour les fans
dont je fais partie tu le sais avant
qu'on se connaît chez lisa toute
l'admiration que j'ai pour toi c'est
compliqué parce que moi j'ai rectifié
tous mes albums chez moi danser quand
même du travail étrangers les noms à
chaque fois donc là il me reste six
places
[Applaudissements]
je fais ça sur tous mes disques et sur
mon passeport il ya toujours vais en igp
alan ça les fait marrer et douaniers
n'ont pas tous oui madame pas de mal
vous parlez souvent et pierre là non ben
oui très souvent et pierre je dois dire
que c'est c'est quelqu'un de je crois
que c'est la personne la plus
protectrice que je connaisse de mes
vieux hommes quoi il a beau avoir 19 ans
mon poids pour moi c'est un vieux mais
enfin c'est un type bourré de talent est
formidable et franchement je je je ne
l'oublient pas je ne loupe pas ex france
gall comment ça va là mais je ne sais
pas vous êtes pareils concilier depuis
l'époque où elle vous traitez de veuve
joyeuse non non c'est jamais parlé ouais
avait jamais en fait non jamais jamais
mais j'ai dit un truc dans un
dans un journal j'ai dis quand même que
les deux seules personnes qui étaient
capables de chanter michel berger c'est
france gall et moi j'aurais pu le faire
plaisir pas de nouvelle bonne nouvelle
d'accord donc c'est et dakar c stand by
comme on dit oui alors quand vous pensez
à votre vie comme ça vous dit ni remords
ni regrets si c'était à refaire je le
referais tout même les malheurs même les
souffrances c'est vrai malheureusement
les roseraies l'on n'est pas tellement
c'est vrai que rillieux les remords j'en
ai un tout petit peu belle vie qu'en
maintenant j'ai bien écouté oui je me
suis bien marré j'ai bien souffert et
puis je me suis dit 'tiens gerona q2
mais sombre gym ou rue des douleurs les
autres les hamsters
vous avez eu des ouvrages du débat on va
faire une interview up and art mais on
est qu'est ce que vous préférez en vous
la paresse
qu'est-ce que vous haïssez en vous ma
vérité votre chanson préférée une
chanson de bioware qui s'appelle
innocente chanoine c'est assez beau ça
c'est une de mes préférées vraiment la
sunshine she's gone
la chanson que vous aimez le moins
souvent que j'aime le moins c'est la
chanson de lara
ah oui
[Musique]
non c'est le père de jardin
c'est guy mauvais c'est ça ouais je t'ai
pas vue et aussi new york new york
vous l'aimez pas ça oui au hasard mais
derrière on dirait on dirait qu'ils
vomissent
[Applaudissements]
ironique le plus grand moment de votre
vie
le plus grand moment de ma vie c'est
d'avoir gagné un concours de cuisine
avec guy savoy et puis 1 et c'était un
concours pro am et pro professionnels
amateurs donc je précise et on a gagné
et on a fait un canard et on le voit le
thème imposé était un canard et moi j'ai
été nul en canards oies canards ça
ressemble un peu oui oui et des non
canard j'ai été obligé de répéter dix
fois j'ai fait une petit canard dans la
cuisine aime ça non c'est vrai c'est le
meilleur moment de votre vie le pire
moment pas cessé d'avoir raté un concert
parce que j'entendais rien et je vais
rater
voilà mais j'étais fatigué c'était à
nice et je me souviens avait michel leeb
c'est en soi non michel leeb que je à
qui je suis tellement reconnaissante qui
a vu que même à l'époque
je m'évanouis c'est un peu et qui a
repris à huy jusqu'au moment où moi j'ai
pu reprendre
et voilà donc ça c'est un des plus
mauvais souvenir pape pour michel leeb
bien sûr que je remercierai est toujours
à genoux enfin je ne m'en fais pas trop
parce que rien qu'est ce que vous
préférez dans la vie prend la rigolade
la rigolade
l'urgence est ce que je préfère c'est
aussi cette espèce de douleur qui porte
et chivu qui vu portes jusqu'à la
rigolade parce qu'on a tellement mal
qu'on se dit allez ça suffit maintenant
alors à rigoler un peu quand même et on
a du mal on a du mal et on est ce qui
vous fait le plus chiant me lever tôt
ouais me levais tôt me lever très tôt
c'est votre plus belle histoire d'amour
c'est là qu'elle s'est
ces scènes avec un homme qu'on admire
parce que dans l'amour il ya tellement
d'admiration
on peut pas aimer quelqu'un sans
l'admirer salué sans se dire tiens non
merveilleux j'aurais voulu faire comme
lui et tout ça donc donc dans l'amour il
ya énormément d'admiration et moi bon
c'est vrai que michel saez ça a été mon
grand amour de la vie mais c'est j'en ai
eu d'autres 1 et j'en ai un autre à
demain maintenant là bas voilà est la
plus moche histoire d'amour n'est pas
non franchement je n'ai pas non non j'en
ai pas d'ailleurs ça se dit pas les plus
moches et plus moche c'est oubliable
jetables c'est comme un vieux kleenex
on les jette on veut pas les garder en
soir va à votre avis véronique qu'est ce
que vous avez de plus sexy en vous rien
bon ah non je vous aurais rien g sauf
peut-être certains de mes regards a
quand même mais je crois que c'est le
seul truc qui est 2 et de moins sexy ce
qu'ils aient de moins sexy on va même
chose puisque rien et sexy donc moins
sexy peut s'écrire
ça va je vois ici comme un ornithorynque
véronique sanson l'album s'appelle long
distance
s'appelle jeanne un homme si les remixes
en sang
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir relate ici ce soir avec eux
puisse votre fils devait pas trouvé de
baby sitter pour l'emmener avec vous
s'il a toujours besoin d'un baby sitter
c'est vrai mais maintenant il en a une
et puis il a un tout petit baby sitter
grand comme ça qu'à cinq mois ce qui est
extraordinaire d'ailleurs vous me faites
penser c'est que chris vous a annoncé
qu'il était perd donc le jour de la mort
de votre père à vous donc de son grand
père comme si la vie finalement
continuer inexorablement c'est à ces
immensités je trouvais que c'était une
bonne idée et je trouve ça j'étais elle
court complètement alors vous êtes ici
parce que vous avez un cd live et un dvd
olympia 2005 véronique sanson et bien un
livre qui paraît chez plon qui s'appelle
la douceur du danger d entretien avec
didier varrault suite au documentaire
sur sur france 3 mais absolument pas ce
qu'on avait finalement tourné pendant 15
heures ce qui est beaucoup
et puis on a
passez juste deux heures huit sur l'a3
et il restait beaucoup de choses dit
beaucoup de réactions suite à ce
documentaire sur vous beaucoup de gens
qui finalement vous en dit vous avez
bien fait de parler de vos problèmes
avec l'alcool etc
je pense que quand on vous pose la
question il faut il faut répondre
honnêtement et sincèrement
sinon ça sert à rien d'occulté les
choses de celles et de ceux les autres
cultes et à soi-même et de les occulter
aux autres parce que les autres savaient
bien tout le monde me regardait d'un air
d'un air de 2 r oui et on dise ah bah
oui la pauvre héros ça va pas du tout il
ya plein de gens qui sont
alcoolique et qu'ils savent pas un bien
sûr ici ils ne savent pas ils se rendent
pas compte
mais bien et quand on s'en aperçoit on
se dit comme toi tu tu en est aperçu
et on m'a invité à dîner chez moi et on
servait du bien à tout le monde et pas
moi et je vous ai dit mais quoi alors
et puis la grèce a dit voilà il a dit à
ma famille qui étaient toutes là je je
ne comprends pas comment vous n'avez pas
vu et vous vous êtes pas aperçu de sa
souffrance et de sa misère habilité
disons parce que moi je me croyais
invisible et je croyais que personne ne
voyait que que ça se voyait pas et tout
ça grâce à chris donc vous en ai de
sortie c'est lui qui vous a sauvé la vie
parce qu'il a dit ça fait des années
qu'il faisait des années que maman est
dans cet état
il a dit à votre famille vous fermez les
yeux vous voyez bien qu'elle boit mais
parce que c'est pas marrant pour un
parent d'avoir une fille est alcoolique
alors on ferme les yeux on ferme les
yeux ça le truc c'est ça le truc c'est
que on ne veut pas on veut pas le savoir
alors maintenant il ya un truc que je
voulais vous dire aussi c'est que c'est
vrai que je parle de l'alcool dans ce
livre et que j'en ai beaucoup parlé dans
le portrait mais il faut aussi dire que
je suis une musicienne
voilà je suis une musicienne je fais des
tournées formidable que je trouve
vraiment génial
[Applaudissements]
ce cimetière
voilà j'ai suivi glissiez années et ça
m'énerve de parler que d'alcool quoi en
ce moment c
rien que de l'eau non ils sont et évite
de mettre à la ce soir oui c'est notre
ami le graminées série voilà juge veut
faire une rectification
le seul truc que je veux dire c'est
qu'on ne doit pas toucher ni à la torah
ni à la bible ni au coran cd livres sens
tu les touches pas ça appartient aux
juifs ça appartient aux arabes
ça appartient aux chrétiens tu n'y
touche pas ça me touche ça me va pas y
passer la soirée mais moi je suis
chrétien tu catholique
mais si quelqu'un a envie de dire du mal
de jésus-christ ou des évangiles je le
laisse libre de le faire c'est la
démocratie
mais alors
aujourd'hui véronique vous avez peur de
rechuter ou non moi j'ai choisi de vivre
une nouvelle vie
alors évidemment quelques fois
évidemment c'est tentant
parce que vous savez c'est révoltant
c'est révoltant de ne pas être comme les
autres ne pas pouvoir boire un p'tit
coup comme les autres comme les autres
et là on trouve une injustice totale
mais la route est très longue et je sais
que dans quand je vais aux alcooliques
anonymes il ya des gens qui qui ont
arrêté depuis 22 ans et qui vous raconte
des trucs absolument mais mes torts dans
monte a déjà demandé un autographe aux
alcooliques anonymes ou pas bien alors
en tous les cas on vous souhaite de ne
jamais retourner dans ce piège mortel
pour moi si je ne souhaite que l'alcool
dans le lit vous parlez aussi de vos
parents on apprend que c'était de grands
résistants vraiment des gens qui ont
donné leur vie quoi pour la france pour
la liberté c'est très bien dans la niche
elle bergé
vous avez fait tellement souffrir en
quittant pour le père de de crise pour
stephen stills
un jour michel berger vous emmène à
l'olympia pour voir crosby still nash et
vous avez là une espèce de coup de
foudre
vous partez acheter des cigarettes mais
vous c'est vrai quoi d'habitude quand on
raconte ça en 18 parties acheter des
cigarettes bon vous c'est vrai vous êtes
vraiment partie de l'avenue non c'est
qu'elle marche
vous dites que c'est un assassinat
ça a failli en être
ç'a failli en être un mais vous savez je
regrette rien et puis j'avais je vais
envie de de changer de vie 2
de changer dit voilà tout simplement et
de d'apprendre autre chose et
d'apprendre autre chose autrement alors
stephen style c'était c'était vraiment
un déjanté notoire à l'époque votre père
et ça vous inquiétez pas ça vous attirer
ceux ce côté dangereux qui l'avait mené
au début je savais pas qu'il était
dangereux mais je ne savais pas dans
quoi je m'aventurais d'aider le jour du
mariage j'avais envie de vous de vous
casser votre soeur violaine vous dit
viens on passe par la fenêtre
il est sur les nerfs sont boucle et là
vous dites je pars pas parce qu'elle est
ou il ya des beatles eux qui sont
invités donc c'est un peu dur de ska et
non résister en fin c'était un peu par
politesse quoi et c'est vrai qu'il y
avait là ma famille la famille de steve
et ces familles qui me qui m'a terrifié
et je me suis dit si je me marie pas bah
ça la fout mal quand même aimé je suis
très content d'avoir fait parce que
sinon voilà voilà en tous les cas ça a
été très compliqué c'est une vraie
plongée dans dans l'alcool dans les
mémoires mais très doucement très
doucement mais qu'est ce qu'ils font
crise quand vous avez du livre ont été
surpris par ce que raconte véronique le
livre je n'ai pas encore lu j'arrive et
je suis parti direct on tournait donc tu
m'appelles montré un parti lui le
passage où elle te déglingue
ça il ya tout ça il ya des moments il ya
des moments très violent quand même un
jour il vous met un coup de tête sans
père 18 points de suture il vous met un
coup de couteau dans le dos on fait
quand même des moments très vous le
saviez ça oui ouais moi je me savais
mais mais mais ils ont été tellement
vraiment j'étais tellement petit quand
ils se sont depuis séparés que j'ai j'ai
pas des souvenirs de saint léon à
raconter quoi vous avez été l'enjeu
d'une bataille terrible finalement votre
mère obtenu votre votre garde mais sa
vie est pris ah oui à quel prix faisait
même failli le tuer son père un moment
vous dites dans le bouquin j'ai eu envie
de le tuer et puis surtout j'ai demandé
combien ça coûte et le devrait des
tueurs à gages non mais moi je rigolais
porte ce n'est pas cher mais vous avez
des séquelles de tout c'est toutes ces
guerres familiale oui i way
non non ça va en avoir la 2 3
mais non les séquelles dont ça se passe
voilà il ya des pas faire ton père ou ta
main
voilà salman rushdie est bien c'est
qu'on perd il va il va comment votre
père va comment votre père il va très
bien il a il a sorti un album l'un album
solo donc le premier depuis 15 ans et ça
se passe bien il y passait en tournée il
ya pas longtemps ici avec crosby et nash
et puis ça va bien ici il s'en sort bien
il est si c'est quelqu'un qui est très
très passionnée de la vie et je crois
que bon il est on a tous un peu vu à
quel point et voilà un des fois quand ça
quand ça comme ça passe ou ça casse quoi
des fois ça casse un drôle de vie
ils ont fait
qu'est ce qu'il
c'est le jeu
véronique sanson
dénombrera en bas
[Musique]
oui
et
et que tu dis moi aussi un autre
en fin d'interview maman a dit alors
tous
est ce que votre mère vous a déjà dit
ton père et moi on va divorcer
oui est ce que votre mère vous a déjà
dit laisse tomber chanteur c'est un
métier de broc et oui vous ai déjà dit
oui le monsieur un peu efféminé c'est
celui avec lequel je vais me marier
crise
non elle me l'a pas dit est ce que votre
mère vous a déjà dit je rentre en france
tu me suis oui est ce que votre mère
vous a déjà dit chris tu vas aller vivre
avec ton père non est ce que votre mère
vous a déjà dit tu compte rester à la
maison jusqu'à quel âge crise sur
l'autre soir est ce que votre mère vous
a déjà dit crise j'ai un amant non est
ce que votre mère vous a déjà dit tu as
des feuilles qu'on roule un pétard
ensemble qu'elle saurait
non non c'est moi et c'est moi qui lui
ai demandé enfin il a pas des
feuilletons je ne sais même pas rouler
un joint
même avec une machine pour ça que je
fais ça parce que tu sais pas oui mais
pour tout dire danser en fait elle elle
me tell me donner l'habitude peuvent
rouler un joint stop le lait est ce que
votre meilleur j'ai déjà dit tu sais
crise si tu es gay c'est pas grave non
est ce que votre mère vous a déjà dit
christ encore oublié de m'appeler pour
mon anniversaire
oui est ce que votre mère vous a déjà
dit je suis fier de toi mon fils tu sais
non jamais non si ça va je dis elle
manie des sujets tous les jours tous les
jours et oui je sais il ya personne qui
plus admiratif et plus supporters et
plus que ma mère il a fallu un bisou non
0 à salé s'est réconciliée est ce que
votre mère vous a déjà dit wilm envers
moi je peux plus
[Musique]